the
so listen during almost my entire
lifetime globalization has been a key
element of our economy it started you
know decades ago it's many industries
wound up manufacturing in particular
offshore jobs to take advantage of lower
labor rates in other countries and so we
lost manufacturing jobs in this country
due to globalization but the other part
of globalization is increasingly the
sp500 the 500 largest companies
domiciled in the United States are
increasingly finding a larger share of
their revenues and profits are coming
from outside the United States
ok and the other part is our trade
relationships the nature of them are
changing due to globalization I'll take
Mexico as an example right now of the
imports to the u.s. from Mexico 40% of
those imports is u.s. content ok so what
is that about it means these are not
just trade relationships these are
integrated supply chains and logistics
that in our judgment at the Dallas Fed
are making the u.s. more competitiveness
competitive likely actually adding jobs
in the United States and keeping those
jobs from going elsewhere most likely to
Asia the last part of globalization that
we have to a couple of more parts I'll
talk about is China is much bigger today
than it was 10 years ago and 20 years
ago and I mean much bigger as a
percentage of global GDP China has been
growing at much higher rates
consistently than almost any other
country in the world except for maybe
India and means they are a larger
percentage of global GDP and they're a
much larger percentage of global GDP
growth ok what's the impact of that they
have been in order to get that growth
and they've been growing recently about
six and a half percent unfortunately in
order to achieve that growth they've
been growing debt to GDP in other words
they have been leveraging in various
sectors
build infrastructure or to build
capacity in many state-owned enterprises
the impact of that is
they've got dramatic over capacity in a
number of their industries which creates
global over capacity and so China bears
watching the world is going to have to
get accustomed to lower levels of growth
from China and also because of currency
outflows that has the potential because
the world is much more financially
integrated currency outflows in China
which is what happened in the first
quarter of 2016 have the potential to
create ripple effects and spill overs
throughout the world and this happened
in the first quarter of 2016 where we
saw financial turmoil and China
translate into rapidly tightening
financial conditions globally so those
are a number of elements of
globalization what's the point of it all
the point of it all is you have to think
about the economy in a much more global
way globalization is likely putting
downward pressure on prices because it's
create because we have more over
capacity and also our trading
relationships have to be thought about
differently because particularly in this
hemisphere it's actually helping US
companies become more globally
competitive and therefore is likely
growing jobs in the United States so as
a central banker it's no longer an
option
in thinking about US monetary policy to
think just about the United States I
have to understand economic conditions
around the world and the
interrelationships between economies and
financial markets around the world
because the ripple effects the spill
overs are much more likely to happen and
this is one reason why when we talk
about the currencies particularly the US
dollar as a central banker I'm much more
sensitive and aware of the impact on the
dollar of central bank actions and also
much more sensitive and aware of the
potential ripple effects of either a
strong or weak dollar not only on the
United States but also on economies
around the world we're just much more
globally interconnected
and so we have to think about the
economy in a different way it's my view
though and I get to the third secular
driver the next one which is technology
enable disruption increasingly I think
globalization is sometimes now being
confused with technology technology
enabled disruption what do I mean by
that 20 years ago and more in you know
in history jobs were lost in number of
locations in the United States because
they were lost overseas and while it
there were a number of benefits of
global trade and globalization United
States we we did a poor job in this
country helping local communities and
workers adjust to the negative effects
of globalization and I'll come back to
that today if you lose your job in a
city in this country it's probably as or
more likely that the reason you're
losing your job is not globalization but
it's technology enabled disruption okay
so things are it's changing people are
attributing it to globalization but it's
probably as or more likely to be due to
the fact that businesses are
increasingly replacing workers with
technology whole industries are being
disrupted out of existence think the
film industry the camera industry while
it still exists has been dramatically
disrupted by you know digital technology
and by handheld phones but this is going
on in retail and even in higher
education going on in every industry and
so what's happening is I think it's
accelerating workers are far more likely
today to lose their jobs or have their
functions changed because of technology
enable disruption technology is
replacing people and in addition because
of technology enable disruption
consumers have much more pricing power
they have the ability to shop with
technology that's putting much more
pressure on businesses
in terms of pricing pressure and
businesses don't have as much pricing
power and that probably is rippling back
through impacts on workers and their
wages and maybe in encouraging
businesses to increasingly replace
workers with technology okay so the
reason the reason this this diagnosis is
important if you think that this is
happening because of globalization you
might take one set of actions if it's
happening because of technology enabled
disruption you might take a different
set of actions and in particular back to
the trade relationship with Mexico I've
been arguing that our trading
relationship as I said earlier with
Mexico helps improve u.s.
competitiveness and keep jobs here and
if we if instead we miss diagnose that
relationship and think that it's
actually hurting US workers we might
actually take steps to dismantle part of
those trading relationships and I think
unfortunately that may actually hurt US
GDP growth I don't think it's going to
help workers locally or it may not help
workers locally because technology
enabled disruption is a bigger issue
that's affecting our workforce on both
those trends though both regarding both
of them it highlights the need for more
workforce development I think of the
worker of today at if you've got a
college education you have a better
chance to manage this if you have some
college or your educational attainment
is either high school or less than high
school you are much more likely to be at
the at the end of this impact and much
less ability to adapt to it okay so much
more likely in people's careers and when
I was a professor at Harvard I used to
tell my students you are far more likely
to get fired than I was you will be your
Fortin far more likely to have to fire
people than I was and you're far more
likely to have the industry you start in
not be the industry you end in because
the industry you start
it may not exist or it's going to be so
different that you're going to have to
adjust so I think it's critical first
because of globalization but now in
particular because of Technology enable
disruption we need to do much more to
help workers adjust to these trends and
help them improve their ability to adapt
and the more educational attainment
either either college or some type of
skills training the more of that you
have the much more likely we are going
to be able to adapt to these trends but
but so so that's the third trend is
technology enable disruption but I think
that and globalization are related and
in today I think some of the effects of
technology enable disruption are being
attributed to globalization and I think
in some cases inaccurately
[Music]
you